hey everyone's Justine how are you I
hope you guys are doing awesome I am
making a very special video today and
this is a video that is an honor of
Steve Jobs it's his birthday on February
24th so I don't know when you guys are
watching this but currently I'm posting
the video on February 25th so Steve
happy birthday I am making you a vintage
Apple logo cake to the best of my
abilities which the best of my cake
making abilities is not very good but
I'm going to try and hopefully it turns
out at least okay for those of you that
have been following me for a while here
on YouTube and on social media and
everywhere online you know that Steve
Jobs for me was such a huge inspiration
and I just only wish that I could have
had a chance to meet him while he was
still here but his legacy will live on
pretty much forever and I'm just so
excited to live in a time to know that I
have on several occasions been in the
same room as Steve Jobs he might have
actually saw me once at an Apple campus
and ran in the opposite direction but
that's okay that's okay not many people
can say that Steve Jobs ran away from
them
I can't so on that note let's bake a
cake how do you say Steven here we have
a painting that one of you guys actually
painted for me and gave it to me at a
conference and for the life of me I have
been trying to find you so if you
painted this for me please
send me a tweet on Twitter I love you
and this still hangs up in my house to
this day not on the refrigerator but
upstairs cake because I want to eat it
god I think I pulled something in my
body too in the freaking they've never
even know choked sorry Steve who's
digging around in there just mixed water
oil egg large it's down I like a boxed
cake mixing master you can call me chef
chef i J
here we go it's a little more than 1/2
cup don't care I got well you're crazy
whole cup of water yep yep yep yep we
gonna mix it good mix this cake just
like should that's really yellow I
should have used egg whites I should
have used egg whites I've really screwed
up it looked very delicious set my alarm
for half an hour in you go beautiful
cake
it's a beautiful cake beautiful cake
mmm oh wow we've got a lot of stuff
going on here I thought I was gonna use
this icing and just like slather it on
there but it's decorating icing and the
consistency is not that good it tastes
nice let's see what the purple looks
like
is this mix enough how many colors in
like that name my icing perspective of
how much I'm actually gonna use is
really really off like really am I gonna
use this whole table I'll put this cake
in the freezer let it cool off for a
little bit and then I'm gonna clean up
this mess and then we're gonna get the
decorating a lot longer than I thought
it would
it's fuzzy here they okay cake cool
something okay it's now time to decorate
I think we're ready
this cake is who freaking frozen oh
that's nice
I got this thing I thought on Amazon
because you can't for you it's magic
okay let's flip this upside down
I got a mmm good even you just go like
that maybe need to be lower
looks pretty loving to me yeah this
doesn't look like this leveled out very
well that makes good hello
let's get our reference image we need to
cut out this little bottom edge doesn't
look bad I think it looks all right
there we go
screen goes from about here so here's
the problem I've got a now go do the
yellow I think I might need to skip a
color I think I'm gonna skip the red
animal you guys know that I'm actually
trying to make this cool and I'm hoping
that I'm slightly succeeding because
it's your Steve and I want it to be
awesome or at least better than most
things that I make in this kitchen
definitely overestimated how much icing
I would need
yeah really working out well not working
out well it's done it's done ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls may I present
to you to the best of my ability a
vintage Apple logo cake like I'm proud
of it
if you look for really far away like
really far away it looks great thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video happy birthday to you
I wish you were here to enjoy this
beautiful cake that I made for you I'll
see you guys in my next video don't
forget to like the video if you liked it
and subscribe for more videos I'll see
you in the next cooking video let me
know in the comments also what you might
like to see me hook next old iPhone
delicious cake hey guys how's it going
so welcome to my first ever virtual
reality video I'm so excited because
this is gonna be so much fun we had an
amazing time shooting this and I hope
that you guys enjoy it as much as I have
enjoyed shooting it